the Queen remains very active for her
the role of monarch is a job for life as
she promised on her 21st birthday shall
be devoted to your service and to the
service of our great imperial family to
which we all belong five years later in
February 1952 her father King George the
sixth died Elizabeth was now Queen at
the age of 25 it's just incredible to
know that someone at that age
appreciated and understood exactly what
was expected of them and to to basically
put Duty ahead of everything else so
early on in her life is quite remarkable
and today more than 60 years later she
takes her royal duties as seriously as
ever she carries out around 400 official
engagements every year her duties also
includes studying cabinet minutes
contained in her famous read dispatch
box and giving the formal royal assent
to new legislation 12th prime ministers
have consulted with her during her reign
from Winston Churchill to David Cameron
her family is also often grateful for
her advice she turns 90 she's a
remarkably energetic and dedicated
guiding force for her family not just
for her family but for an entire nation
a reassuring presence in a turbulent
world now 90 and still going strong